en este diagrama tenemos un gran
triángulo que tiene adentro varios
triángulos más pequeños y lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es encontrar este
pequeño ángulo de aquí y vamos a llamar
a este ángulo theta y tenemos más
información aquí como por ejemplo que
estos son ángulos rectos que a lo mejor
ustedes ya lo habían notado recordemos
que los ángulos rectos son ángulos de 90
grados como este de aquí y este otro
también sabemos que este ángulo es de 32
grados así que veamos que podemos hacer
para resolver esto de diferentes maneras
ya que existen varias maneras de
resolverlo entonces queremos que este
ángulo de aquí es theta y vemos que este
ángulo theta es adyacente a este otro
ángulo a este ángulo verde y si lo
sumamos vamos a tener este ángulo recto
o este ángulo de 90 grados entonces este
ángulo rosso a este ángulo theta más el
ángulo verde deben dar como resultado 90
grados así que podemos escribir este
ángulo verde como 90 menos theta grados
y ahora ya tengo tres ángulos de este
triángulo y sólo tengo que resolverlo
para theta y sabemos que si sumamos
estos tres ángulos nos deben dar 180
grados aquí escribo 90 menos theta más
este ángulo recto que es 90 grados más
90 más este otro ángulo 32 grados y esto
debe ser igual a 180 grados aquí escribo
180 estamos tomando todos estos ángulos
internos para sumarlos y que la suma nos
de 180 grados es lo que estamos haciendo
aquí ahora vamos a ver si podemos
simplificar un poquito más esto 90 más
90 180 menos 3 el ángulo theta más 32
grados igual a 180 que más tenemos aquí
y bueno tenemos 180 de ambos lados de la
ecuación así que lo quitamos
nos queda menos teta 32 igual a 0
despejamos aquí la teta la pasamos hacia
el otro lado y nos queda 32 igual a teta
o teta igual a 32 aquí escribo 32 y que
creen este es el mismo ángulo que
teníamos aquí y esta es sólo una manera
de resolver el problema hay muchas otras
formas de hacerlo por ejemplo podemos
haber dicho bueno vamos a considerar
este triángulo grande y ya que este
ángulo de aquí es de 90 grados este otro
es de 32
así que este ángulo de casa será 180
menos 90 menos 32 pues todos estos
tienen que sumar 180 grados y creo que
me salte un paso porque esto bueno lo
mejor no nos saltemos pasos vamos a
llamar a esto x x más 90 recordemos que
estamos viendo este triángulo más grande
de aquí
así que x más 90 más este ángulo de aquí
32 todo esto debe ser igual a 180 grados
así que vamos a quitar 90 y 32 de ambos
lados así que quitamos 90 aquí 180 menos
90 quedan 90 y si ahora quitamos 32 en
ambos lados nos va a quedar x igual a 58
grados x igual a 58 grados
muy bien qué más podemos encontrar
buenos y tenemos que este ángulo de aquí
es un ángulo recto y recuerden que solo
estoy volviendo a hacer el problema de
aquí para que vean que hay diferentes
maneras de resolverlo si este ángulo de
aquí es de 90 grados este ángulo de aquí
es suplementario y también tendrán 90
grados para tomar un total de 180 ahora
si tomo este ángulo más este ángulo más
este ángulo debo tener un total de 180
grados en este ángulo y así que y más 58
más 90 igual a 180 vamos a simplificar
esto quitando 90 de ambos lados de la
ecuación aquí nos va a quedar 90 y si
quitamos 58 de ambos lados nos va a
quedar ye igual a 32 si este ángulo es
igual a 32 este ángulo de acá va a ser
complementario este ángulo
complementario vamos a ponerle de otro
color y el ángulo complementario no
suplementario ya que esto es un ángulo
recto de 90 grados este ángulo lo vamos
a llamar zeta
y estos dos tienen que sumar 90 grados
así que z va a ser igual a 58 grados y
ahora ya estamos en el triángulo que nos
interesa el que contiene a teta teta
cuyo valor ya encontramos hace un
momento sí aquí tenemos 58 grados y este
es un ángulo recto esto va a ser un
ángulo suplementario así que tenemos 58
grados 58 no mejor lo voy a poner del
otro color 58 grados más este 90 más
este ángulo teta teta todo esto debe ser
igual a 180 grados
ahora quitamos 90 de ambos lados de la
ecuación nos queda 58 más teta igual a
90 quitamos 58 de ambos lados y nos
queda theta igual a 32 que es el mismo
resultado que obtuvimos la vez pasada de
nuevo les comento hay muchas maneras de
resolver esto y mientras ustedes hagan
las cosas de una manera consistentemente
lógica siempre van a llegar
el resultado correcto